here's a guy whose mouth can sound like
an engine and this woman can be a human
car alarm but are those the best mouth
noises of all time and better yet what
happened to my beer well to figure out
the answer to this one you'll have to
wait for the key of Awesome's new music
video on Thursday but don't let it
distract you ladies let's focus on the
mouth and mouth noises and the best of
all time all aboard the boat here's an
old man who would do a monkey and a
horse on the aquatic side here's a
dolphin woman this guy can mimic the
sound of a pistol reloading and if you
want something wetter this kid opens and
pours a can of coke when things get
awkward call over Fletcher 901 who can
give you some great cricket noises to
fill the silence competitive whistlers
are incredible one of the neatest
whistle tricks I've seen is the ability
to whistle through two or more openings
in your mouth so you can make multiple
tones and harmonize with yourself
[Music]
of course beatboxers are some of the
most famous noise makers on youtube some
newer clips show beatboxers doing
dubstep sounds like rapes one links by
the way to all these noises are in the
description below also worth a listen is
master mic beatbox
I mean look how much fun this guy is
happening while you're jamming to that I
want to invite you into my own little
experiment on Thursday the next Vsauce
video on this channel will come out at
exactly 6 p.m. Eastern the first 100
people to get there and comment the word
boo ears will get a YouTube message
specially from me so you have to be
there right at 6 p.m. let's see what
happens and as always thanks for
watching